CARTER MORGAN: We talked about
Container Builder before,
but we only really scratched
the surface of what it can do.
In this episode of the
Cloud Rolling Update,
it's time to play
with multi-step
builds in Container Builder.
Special thanks, again,
to Ahmet and Kelsey
for teaching me about this.
Make sure to check out
their content linked
in the description below.
A single Dockerfile doesn't
always get you what you need.
And in fact, it's common
to use multiple steps
in a build pipeline to
build, test, and deploy
enterprise applications, which
means a tool that can only
build Docker images isn't that
useful for creating real world
applications.
Luckily, Container Builder
isn't just a Docker builder.
By allowing you to run multiple
build steps, each of which
can run any Docker image
as part of your build,
well, it provides a
simple and powerful way
to customize build steps
and build environments.
You might be wondering,
why is that useful?
Well, it allows you to run
unit tests with your build
or reduce the size
of your final image
by rebaking your image
onto a leaner, smaller base
image that removes
build artifacts,
test tooling, and other crud.
So to run this
feature for yourself,
here's what you need to know.
You can customize build steps
with a cloudbuild.yaml file.
Each build step
runs in a container.
You can bring your
own container images
or use Google-provided ones.
Your repository is
mounted at /workspace.
And contents of /workspace are
preserved from one build step
to another.
And this is exactly like
Jenkins build pipelines,
where you have artifacts
that are stashed or unstashed
from one step of the
pipeline to the next.
This means that if you
distribute your apps
as containers,
well, you don't need
to host a Jenkins instance
or a third party CI service
to build and push images.
So to illustrate this
better, let's use
GCB to build, test, and package
an example go application.
I want to remember that
when I submit the build GCB,
my source code is pulled
into a workspace directory.
From there, GCB
runs the commands
that I specify over the contents
of that workspace directory.
It's also good to know
that the Container Builder
team publishes and maintains
a set of Docker containers
with common developer
tools, like get, docker,
the gcloud command
line interface.
So I can use any of these to run
operations inside of my build.
Now, using these
tools, I'm going
to define a
cloudbuild.yaml file.
This has a pipeline
with a specific set
of steps to run, just
like in any build system.
But instead of storing
these images locally,
we use the ones that
are stored in the cloud.
First, go-install
will produce a binary
that I can use in my next step.
Then we'll use the go
Docker container image again
to test our code.
Finally, we'll use a Docker
container to build an image.
This assumes that there is a
Dockerfile in my workspace.
If all of the above steps pass,
then the final result of this
will be gcb example image.
When I submit the build, you
can see all of these steps
from the cloudbuild.yaml
file run it.
So what's the point?
Container Builder is not just
for building Docker containers.
But it's a composable
ecosystem that allows
you to use any build step.
For more information
about this, be
sure to check out the
links from Ahmet and Kelsey
in the description below.
And to learn about more advanced
features of Google Container
Builder, like using
build triggers
to automate creating
containers, be
sure to subscribe
to the channel.
I'm Carter Morgan.
And I'm telling you
to tune in next time
to learn what's rolling out in
the next Cloud Rolling Update.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching.
Check out previous episodes
of Cloud Rolling Update.
And click here to watch Kelsey's
next talk on Container Builder.
See you next time.